so now that you've officially met
everyone oh yes yes yes yes um i have to
lead with this yes she was one of my
favorite singers okay so i have to leave
her i can't even believe you're the son
in the bodyguard it's crazy to me
like i i did not like i've seen himself
and i think because you were so little i
didn't transl i did did not translate to
me and i just found it was that i know
you're probably tired of this but
i have to ask because she's whitney um
what was that like do you remember cause
you were so little yes i was so little
it was it was mind-blowing but you know
one of the things i remember i was eight
so i didn't even care about when you
used it at that time right now i think
it's so funny
it was it was the first time i actually
saw snow so i i was just like oh cool
this is great and and you know since
they're like yeah yeah whitney houston
kevin cosby
yeah
regardless and and i remember she took
me into her trailer one time and she was
singing and i was like oh dang girl you
can sing look
[Laughter]
she probably loved that i think that's
so it's so it's so innocent apparent
it's just such a huge like i mean
speaking of huge pop culture things with
friends and like the bodyguard there's
huge moments and i did not
like i didn't know you were the same kid
like i didn't know that and i'd seen you
in seven and i was like wait what yeah
anyway so i had to ask
[Music]
you